[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العنوي
بريطانيا
عقوبات جديده ضد طائره
وزير الدفاع الالمانيه
قبل ارسال دبابات اليوكرانيا
اصبحت حقيقيه
رئيس الحكومه العراقيه يقع في محافظه
البنك المركزي من منصبه بعد ارتفاع
الدولار
وشركات الامريكيه تتوقع تقليص الوظائف
خلال العام الحالي وشركات التكنولوجيا
تواصل تسريحه الاف الموظفين
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه اعلنت الحكومه
البريطانيه فرض عقوبات جديده على مسؤولينا
وكيانات ايرانيه لدورهم في انتهاكات حقوق
الانسان في البلاد
واوضحت لندن ان العقوبات شملت تجميد اصول
قائد القوات البريه في الجيش الايراني
ونائب القائد العام للحرس الثوري ونائب
قائد ميليشيا الباسيس وحضرهم من السفر
كما قررت الحكومه البريطانيه تجميد اصول
الفسيخ مؤكده ان العقوبات تعكس ادانه
العنف الذي يمارسه النظام بحق شعبه بما في
ذلك اعدامه لبريطاني الايراني علي رضا
اكبر
بدوره قال وزير الخارجيه لبريطاني جيمس
كليبرري ان بلاده فرضت 50 عقوبه جديده
مرتبطه بانتهاكات حقوق الانسان في ايران
منذ مقتل مهسى امين
ومع استمرار النظام في قمع التظاهرات
الاحتجاجيه اعلن الاتحاد الاوروبي
الموافقه على فرض حزمه عقوبات جديده ضد
دائره مشيرا الى ان الحزمه الجديده تستهدف
قاده ايرانيين متهمين باستخدام القمع ضد
المتظاهرين
وجدد الاتحاد الاوروبي رفضه لاستخدام
القوه بشكل وحشيه من قبل السلطات
الايرانيه ضد المتظاهرين السلمي
[موسيقى]
رئيس البرلمان الايراني محمد باقر قلباف
اعتبر ان العقوبات الامريكيه على طهران
وموسكو تشكل اكبر تهديدا في الوقت الرحم
واضاف قلبك في مؤتمر صحفي مع رئيس مجلس
النواب الروسي فيات سلاف فولودين ان
الضغوط على البلدين تتطلب العمل المشترك
والتعامل الاستراتيجي لتجاوز المرحله
بدوره اعتبره لان العقوبات الامريكيه
تساهم في دفع العلاقات بين البلدين قائلا
ان الحاضر الذي تفرضه امريكا وحلفائها
سيدفع الى المزيد من الانسجام والتعاون
بين موسكو وطهره
هذا وحذر وزير خارجيه النمسا من ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يريد اي سباق تسلح في
المنطقه في الوقت الذي تتحرك فيه ايران
بالاتجاه الخاطئ وترسل المسيرات والمعدات
الحربيه الى روسيا
هو موضوع سباق التسلح النووي في منطقه
الخليج ايران بسرعه كبيره في الاتجاه
الخاطئ من خلال شحنه الطائره بدون طيار
والمعدات الحربيه الى روسيا وما تقوم به
من قمع لشعبها لذا فان العقوبات ضروريه
كما اعلن وزير الخارجيه النمسا عن ادراج
37 شخصا وكيانا جديدا على قائمه عقوبات
الاتحاد الاوروبي مشيرا الى ان هذه
الاجراءات ستستمر بسبب تورط ايران في
جرائم يحارب بشكل غير مباشر
37 شخصا وكيانا جديدا على قائمه عقوبه
الاتحاد الاوروبي وستمر هذه الاجراءات
علينا مواصله الضغط طالما ان ايران تشارك
بشكل غير مباشر في جرائم الحرب وترسل
طائره بدون طيار وربما صواريخ الى روسيا
الى بروكسل حيث مراسل العربي نور الدين
الفريدي يتابع كل هذه التطورات نور اهلا
وسهلا بك جديده التحركات والمواقف
الاوروبيه نور فيما خاص العقوبات الجديده
على ايران وهل فعلا يمكن للاتحاد الاوروبي
ان يتبنى توصيه البرلمان بتصنيفرس الثوري
على لائحه الارهاب ام لا موقف جوزيف بورن
اليوم يعيد خلط الاوراق من جديد
يوضح الموقف الصحيح
والقانوني يبقى سياسي ممكن نتحدث فيه
لاحقا جوزيف قال ان القرار بشان ادراج
الحرس الثوري الايراني في قائمه الارهاب
يرتبط اولا من قبل كل شيء بصدور حكم
قضائيا في دوله من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
على ان تنقل هذه الدوله هذا الطلبه هذا
الحكم الى طاوله الاتحاد الاوروبي حتى
اليوم لا لم تحاكم اي دوله من دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي متهمينه مرتبطين مباشره
الايراني
يعني قاعده اساسيه لا يمكن تجاوزها باي
حال من الاحوال لان اي قرار اخر يمكن فيه
امام محكمه العدد الاوروبي ومن هناك فان
جوزيف ازال كل الغموض كل الجدل
الذي دار على مداء الايام الماضيه همم
بسبب عدم وضوح الموقف من الناحيه
القانونيه طيب لكن ايه بس نور معنا يعني
سنعود اليها ولكن في هذه النقطه الا يعتبر
ذلك تراجع عن اوروبيا او للنقل مخرج
للاوروبيين لعدم تصنيف الحارس الثوري على
الاقل في هذه المرحله على لائحه الارهاب
وبالتالي الاتحاد الاوروبي لن يستفز ايران
اطلاقا له اطلاقا لا لان الحرس الثوري
الايراني كبار المسؤولين فيه حتى في قائمه
اليوم هناك خمسه جنرالات من جنرالات
الحارس السوري
الان في هذه الحزمه الرابعه من العقوبات
التي صدرت قبل نحو ساعه في الجريده
الرسميه الاوروبيه واثني عشر كيانا تابعا
للحارس الفوري هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى
الحرس الثوري المدرج في قوائم العقوبات
حول سوريا مدرج في قوائم مسيرات الى روسيا
مدرج منذ العام 2010 مثل ما اكدت وزيره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاترين كلنا ندرج منذ
العام 2010 في قائمه العقوبات المتصله
بحذر الانتشار النووي والحرس الثوري مسؤول
عن همم عن نشر هذه التكنولوجيا واستخدام
الصواريخ البالستيه وتطويره لبرنامج
صواريخ الرئيسيه
رغمته وبالتالي همم القول من انا الاتحاد
الاوروبي يتراجعوا يخضع للضغوط لا غير
صحيح يعني
الموضوع هو
المنهجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي هو استهداف
المسؤولين في الحارس الثوري بشكل منتظما
وهذه الحزمه الرابعه تؤكد هذا الاتجاه
التصعيد من جانب الاتحاد الاوروبي ردا على
قمعي ايران المنهج للمتظاهرين بالتالي لكن
المثل الاخرى من الناحيه الدبلوماسيه
النقاش مفتوح بين الدبلوماسيين الاوروبيين
انا انا
هل نتوقع ان تقوم هل نتوقع ان تقوم دوله
اوروبيه ما في الايام المقبله باصدار هذا
مثل هكذا قرار همم قائد ضد الحرس الثوري
وبالتالي يعطي مشروعيه للاتحاد لان يتبنى
همم هذا القرار ويصنف الحرس على لائحه
الارهاب املا هذا السبعه
يعني مستبعه دون حضرتك فضلت قلت الايام
المقبله هذا مستبعد في الاسابيع والاشهر
المقبله لان نحن لان الاتحاد
على اسس ومبادئ دوله القانون وبالتالي
هناك مثلا هناك تحقيقات جاريه في المانيا
يتعلق بحاله
محدده ربما تتصل ربما لها سلات بالحرس
الثوري الايراني هذه تحقيقات حسب زميلاتنا
في برلين ستستمر ربما اشهر واشهر وما من
هنا الى نهايه العام ولكن هذا الشغل
القضاء شغل يعني همم والقضاء مستقل في
هيئه في هذه المساله وبالتالي يجب همم
الاخذ بعين الاعتبار بان هذه مساله اساسيه
ممكن من الاركان التي يقوم عليها الاتحاد
هي احترام ما بين دوله القانون الان اذا
سمحت همم
ورد حديثا يعني قبل ساعات في قائمه
العقوبات همم الرابعه ضد همم الحاله
الثوري الايراني خمسه جرارات اليوم وهم
مثلا همم
احمد رئيس فريق كربلاء في الحرس الثوري
الايراني همم ايضا احمد عظيم رئيس قسم
النجف الاشرف في الحارس الثوري الايراني
عباس مرتضى نائب قائد الحرس الثوري
الايراني اا مسلم معين رئيس مقر البسيج او
سكنه البسيج او هي دي كوارتر تبع البسيج
في الامن السيبراني قائد الحارس السوري في
محافظه باريس الثاني قائد الحارس الثوري
في محافظه كربلاء
17 هم من المحافظين ورجال الامن
والمسؤولين في الاذاعه والتلفزيون
التكنولوجيا الكيانات هي ايضا همم اكثر من
20 الى 20 كيان في هذه القائمه 12 كيانا
تابعا للحرس السوري الايراني
حقوق الانسان في ايران وصلت الان الى مئه
وواحد 161 مسؤولا ايرانيه 32 كيانا
ساكتفي بهذا القدر من بروكسل مراسل العربي
نور الدين الفريدي شكرا جزيلا لك نور على
كل هذه متابعه
وفي سياق متصل لهذه التطورات افاد مسؤول
السياسه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جزر كما
ذكرنا انه لا يمكن للاتحاد ان يصنفسه
الثوري الايراني على انه جماعه ارهابيه
قبل صدور حكم قضائي بذلك في احدى الدول
الاعضاء في التكتل وانه امر لا يمكن البث
فيه بدون محكمه
وكان البرلمان الاوروبي قد طلب مجلس
الاتحاد الاوروبي والدول الاعضاء باضافه
الحارس الثوري والقوات التابعه له على
قائمه الارهاب بما في ذلك قوات البسيج
وفيلقلق القدس
المزيد من المتابعه ايضا ينضم اليه من
باريس الان المحامي والخبير في القانون
الدولي مجيد بودان استاذ مجيد اهلا وسهلا
بك الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه اولا ما
الذي نفهمه من موقف السيد جوزيف اليوم من
انه لا يمكن تصنيف الحرس الثوري الايراني
على هذه القائمه الا بقرار محكمه بقرار
قضائي من احدى الدول الاوروبيه هل هذا
هروب الى الامام ام تراجع من قبل
الاوروبيين ماذا برايي
هي لغه الدبلوماسيه لان همم هناك مفاوضات
هناك همم تسعيد هناك جذب
يعني هذا السلع في هذا السباع يمكن
للاتحاد الاوروبي
بان يستعمل مكونات
المؤسساتها اي من الاتحاد
الهيئه التنفيذيه الاوروبيه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه او القضاء ولكن همم كل له
تصنيفه يمكن البرلمان ان يصنف ولكن هذا
يبقى من مساله التشريع ومسيله همم السياسه
السلطه التنفيذيه المفوضيه يمكن لها ان
تسنف ولكن يبقى العمل سياسي وليس له مفعول
ويمكن ان كذلك ان تتخذ قرارات على هذا
الاساس ولكن الاساس في عمل هو ان تكون
التوصيف التوثيف يجب ان يكون قانونيا
قضائيا وبالتالي بس سؤال مثلا نريد ان
نفهم المشاهدين من الناحيه القانونيه هل
يحتاج الامر الى قرار قضائي مبرا من احدى
الدول الاوروبيه ام لا هذه مجرد حجه
وذريعه من السيد بويرل لعدم ادراج الحرس
الثوري على لائحه الارهاب في هذه المرحله
هي مثل هناك 90 في في العمليه همم لا هناك
همم الان وضع الدقيق هناك رهاء الاوروبيين
همم لا يريدون اعطاء الدقيقه لايران في
ذلك هناك همم هذه السيارات السيارات
الى روسيا لا يريدون كذلك يتحدث سعيد ولكن
يريد ان يؤكد ان المسار هو في اتجاه ادراج
هذه المنظمه كمنظمه ارهابيه هناك اليه
تستعمل هذه الاليات اذا ارادت المفوضيه ان
تعلن ذلك يمكن لها ان تعني ذلك لكن القرار
يكون همم يكون همم سياسي وان وقع التجميد
اموال او وقعه ايقاف اشخاص فهذا القارئ
ليس له فعاليه امام القبائل الاوروبي
وبالتالي هناك تح المانيا سرحت امس انها
يمكن ان تقوم بذلك يجب ان ننتظر الايام
القليله او الاسابيع القليله القادمه كيف
سيحدث
يقول لك البعض انه الاتحاد الاوروبي كان
صنف كيانات وجماعات على لائحه الارهاب في
السابق
ولم يحكام قضائيه او هذه الاليه المتبعه
فلماذا الان يحتاج او يحاوج في موضوع
الاليه والحكم القضائي
صحيح ويجب ان نبتعد عن التفكير ان هناك
سياسه المكيلين التي تتردد دائما لكن
العمليه اكثر دقه العمليه هنا مساله وجود
بهائم وساله الدهونات مساله حرب اوكرانيا
يتحرك فيها الاتحاد الاوروبي بشكل اكثر
بشكل اكثر ولكن يبني على عمليه هي متواصله
وهاتي العمليه هي الان تحت البناء لا يجب
ان يكون هناك تسرع في هذا في هذا القرار
هناك عمليه تجميع للادله هناك محاكمات
ستسير والقرار سيتاخذ الاتجاه واضح في ذلك
لانه هناك ادله كافيه تجعل
الكمنيه والده وسيكون وستكون الامكانيه
هذه همم يعني مفعله من باريس المحامي
والخبير في القانون الدولي مجيد ودان شكرا
جزيلا لك استاذ مجيد على هذه المشاركه
وفي سيناريو شبيه بمقتل الشاب ماسه امينه
اعلى منظمه ايران لحقوق الانسان ان احد
المعتقلين في الاحتجاجات الاخيره دخل في
غيبوبه بسبب اصابته بجروح اثناء الاعتقال
ووفقا المنظمه فان حسن فيروزي عانى من
نزيف حاد بعد التعذيب والضرب على يد
المحققين في غضون ذلك قال محامي المعتقل
محمد اختياريان في خرم اباد غربي ايران ان
موكله سقط في غيبوبه ايضا بسبب اصابته
بجروح اصيب بها اثناء الاعتقال
في ايران ايضا تداول نشطاء مقطعا مصورا
يظهر فيه عناصر امن بلباس المدني يعتدون
على فتاتين
[موسيقى]
نشاط الخامس مستمره فيها ايضا
اليونسكو تخصص اليوم الدولي للتعليم في
الرابع والعشرين من يناير للفتيات والنساء
الافغانيه
ا جاء موعد فيتامين اللي ما تلقاه الا من
برا الحين تركيز 200 ملي ولا 100 ليش لازم
ادفع اكثر عشان توصل الشحنات اسرع
اسبوع اسبوعين الين تجين فيتاميناتها اللي
يمكن ما تكون في احسن حالتها لكن الوضع
الحين غير نفس صار عندها
اون لاين
[موسيقى]
اللي يناسبها ويكون عنده خلال يومين بس
نهدي قلوبل من النهدي
[موسيقى]
ان تكون جاهزا لنقل الخبره يعني وجودك في
موقع الحدث
وكفاءه مراسلك على الارض
هو قدرتك على الرؤيه من زوايا متعدده
لتغطي الحدث من جميع الجوانب ما يجعلك
الافضل هو قيامك بتجزئه الملفات والرط بين
عناصرها مع الاستعانه بالخبراء والمحللين
مهمتنا ان ننظر من جميع الزوايا لجعل
الاخبار اكثر فهما العربيه
على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
باريس باستوريوس الى التحلي بالصبر بشان
قراري بلاده رساله دبابات اثنان الى
المانيا
قريبا بشان هذا الموضوع سيتم اتخاده لكن
يجب ان اخذه في الحسبان ان هذه الدبابات
تستخدم لاغراض هجوميه وعلى المانيا
التفكير ماليا قبل ادخالها في الحرب
الى انه من مصلحه المانيا اتخاذ القرار
بعنايه لانه قد يؤثر على امن سكانها وان
موقفها الواضح وانها لن تدخل في الحرب
الكرملين كان قد هدد بان الشعب الاوكراني
سيدفع ثمن امداد كليب بالدبابات الالمانيه
عبر دول اخرى وقال المتحدث باسم الكرملين
بميتر بيسكوف ان كل الدول التي تزود
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه يجب ان تتحمل المسؤوليه
واضاف بسكوب انه يجب التواصل مع الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بشان المعلومات عن
تخزين الثياب اسلحه في المحطات النوم
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه الى بروف قال ان
الحرب بين بلاده والغرب اصبحت حقيقه ولم
تعد هجينا وخلال مؤتمر الصحفي مع نظيره
الجنوب افريقي في بريتوريا اتهم على بروف
الغرب بالاستعداد للحرب ضد روسيا منذ فتره
طويله لتدمير كل ما هو روسي على حد تعبير
كما دافع عن اجراء روسيا مناورات بحريه
مشتركه مع الصين وجنوب افريقيا
انها حرب وليست هجينه انها حرب حقيقيه
تقريبا كان الغرب يخطط لها لفتره طويله ضد
روسيا والهدف هو تدمير كل شيء روسي من
اللغه الى ثقافه السائده
بلغتهم الامه
السفينه الحربيه الروسيه المسلحه
بالصواريخ فرق الصوتيه التي ستشارك في
مناورات الصين وجنوب افريقيا الشهر المقبل
تدخل ضمن ابراز روسيا لاسلحتها الجديده
الى الواجهه في ظل استمرار الحرب في
اوكرانيا
السفينه تحمل صواريخ تحلق بسرعه تتجاوز
سرعه الصوت ب 9 اضعاف
وتقول روسيا ان مداها يصل الى اكثر من
1000 كلم
صواريخ ابا نجار دخلت الخدمه القتاليه عام
2019 وهي عباره عن صواريخها انزلاقيه يزن
الصاروخ حوالي الكيلوغرام وهو قادر على
حمل رؤوس النوويه وتقليديه
ويتم نقله ابن جارد الى اقصى ارتفاع
بواسطه صاروخ باليستيك بعدها تنفصل
المرتبه عن صاروخها ثم تنطلق نحو هدفها
عبر الغلاف الجوي
قالت المخابرات الاوكرانيه انها تتوقع
قتالا شرسا في لوغانس ودونيستك في شهري
فبراير ومارس واكلت المخابرات ان ذلك ياتي
بناء على معلومات سريه حصلت عليها بان
بوتين امر قوتي بالاستلاء على كامل الضم
باس بحلول مارس مشيره الى ان الجيش الروسي
بدا في تغيير تكتيكاته العسكريا
مخابرات اوكرانيا اضافت ان تقييم روسيا
لقوات كليب اصبح اكثر واقعيه في الوقت
الحالي
معي من موسكو لبزيد من المتابعه عبد
الجواد رشد مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد اهلا
وسهلا بك اخر اخبار الشريط الميداني
والمعارك تحديدا همم في باخموت وزابولوجيا
مساء الخير طالب نعم بالفعل يعني المعارك
والاخبار الوارده من هناك تتحدث عن احتدام
المعركه في عده مناطق اسمح لي في البدايه
اللي بان ان انوه لهذا العاجل بان من طاقه
همم كراماتورس الان تتلقى ضربه صاروخيه
كما يتحدث عمده المدينه منذ نحو دقيقتين
من الان قام بنشر مقطع فيديو يظهر او تظهر
في اعمده الدخان تتصاعد في المدينه اكرر
بانها مدينه كراماتوست تتعرض لضربه
صاروخيه على الجانب الاخر ايضا همم نوفا
كخوف كطالب التي تقع في خرسون حيث توجد
المحطه الكهرومائيه وصل عدد الضرب
المدفعيه من قبل الجانب الاوكراني حسب
روايه روايه سلطات المدينه هناك الى 14
صاروخا او اربعه عشره قذيفه طالب على
العموم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه في بيانها
اليوم تتحدث عن تحييد عشرات الجنود
الاوكرانيين في مناطق مختلفه في لوغانس
وفي اطراف دانيال ستتحدث عن تقدم نوعي
لبضعه كيلومترات في شمال زباروجه على ما
يبدو ان السيطر على بق- على بعض
المستوطنات السكنيه في تلك المناطق والقرى
تجري الان في تلك المنطقه لكن طبعا ما خرج
اليوم
وهو رئيس الاستخبارات الروسيه الخارجيه
بحديثه عن ان كيف تقوم بحشد الذخيره
والمعدات العسكريه في اراضي المحطات
النوويه الاوكرانيه هو امر مقلق بشكل كبير
وامر خطير كما سماه البعض ما ليش كنت
تتحدث عن ان الاسبوع الاخير من شهر ديسمبر
الماضي شهد طبعا همم يعني حشد وجمع ونقل
هذه المعدات
بقطارات عبر عربتها الى بعض الناطق
النوويه على ما يبدو طالب في معلومه اخيره
ان الحديث يدور عن المحطات التي لا تسيطر
عليها موسكو وبذلك تخرج تخرج خيار
زاباروجي عن الموضوع باعتبار ان المحطه
والمناطق المحيطه بها حطهم فاهم ابقى معي
عبد ال- ال- ابقى معي عبد الجواد انضمت
الي راغده بهنان من برلين وايضا حذيفه
عادل من كيف راكده موقف لافت اليوم لوزير
الدفاع الالماني الجديد هل يستشف من موقفه
هذا
ان برلين لم تتورط في ارسال دبابات اثنان
الى كيف اقل له في المدى المنظور خصوصا
عندما يقول يجب ان نفكر ماليا قبل ارسال
هذه الدبابات لانها دبابات هجوميه وان هذا
القرار سيؤثر على امن السكان الالمان ما
الذي يستشف من هذا الكلام
اهلا طالب اولا هذا هو السبب الرسمي الذي
تقول المانيا بانها لم توافق على ارسال
يعني هي شخصيا هذه الدبابات الى اوكرانيا
بعد ولكن ايضا هناك سبب اخر المتحدث باسم
الحكومه الالمانيه اليوم قال بانه الحكومه
لم تتلقى بعد ولا اي طلب رسمي من اي دوله
تطلب ان ترسل هذه الدبابات الى اوكرانيا
تعرف انه بحكم العقود التي تم توقيعها بين
الدوله التي اشترت هذه الدبابات لعبه
اثنين من المانيا هي بحاجه لان تاخذ
موافقه الحكومه الالمانيه قبل ان ترسلها
الى دوله ثالثه لذلك الان الحكومه تقول
بانه عندما تتلقى هذا الطلب ستبحث به من
الناحيه القانونيه وتعطي ردها رئيس وزراء
بولندا ايضا كان يقول اليوم بانه سيتقدم
قريبا الى الحكومه الالمانيه بهكذا طلب
يبدو ان الاتصال انقطع مع راغده لنا عوده
اليها بعد قليل الى حذيفه عادل حذيفه
اخبار الشريط الميداني جديد اخبار القصف
وايضا يعني كما كانت تقول راغده هل لدى
كيف تطمنينات من ان الاوروبيين عاجلا ام
اجلا سينصعوه للضغوط الامريكيه ويرشلون
هذه الاسلحه الحديثه سواء ليوبارد اثنان
او انظمه باتريوت كما تقول كانت تقول
هولاندا الكيف
تحياتي طالب في الحقيقه ما زالت كيف تحافظ
على تصريحات متوازنه بشان هذه القضيه تعلم
ان هنالك كان كثير من النقد المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين لاسيه مع مستشار رئيسكي في
القضايا الخلافيه مع الشركاء وكان هناك
بعض من التصريحات الحاده بعض الشيء لذلك
الان في هذه القضيه هم يحافظون على
تصريحات متوازيين قبل قليل تحدث
رئيسكي همم حول هذا الموضوع وقال ببساطه
شديده انه نحن للفوز في هذه الحرب وهذه
الحرب ليست حرب اكرانيه وهي انما هي همم
حرب همم للعداله وانما هي حرب تخص الجميع
ان جبهه اوروبا الاساسيه في الدفاع عن
اوروبا الان هي اوكرانيا لذلك على الجميع
لارسال الدبابات
الى 10 او 20 دبابه وانما الى مئات
الدبابات للحفاظ على
جبهه الدفاع عن اوروبا وعن العداله
والديمقراطيه كما اقل هذا من جانب
الرئيسكي ايضا كانت تصريحاته في اشياء
كثير من التصميم للجانب الالماني حيث قال
ان هذه الدبابات سوف تسير على ارض
اوكرانيه وانها لن تسير على الاراضي
الروسيه طبعا في اشاره لانه لن يكون هنالك
هجوم وقال نحن نسعى الى الوصول الى حدود
1991 الحدود المعترف بها دوليا هذا من
جاري في هذه القضيه اليوم طبعا ايضا طالب
يعني يعلوا على صوت المعركه ويعني وعلى
صوت جبهات القتال هو قضايا الفساد الداخل
التي يتم الداخليه سواء كان البرلمان
اليوم العقده وكان هنالك جلسه خاصه للحديث
وسائل الاعلام الاخرانيه والتحقيقات التي
قام بها بعض الاعلاميين الصحفيين
الاوكرانيين حول قضاء الفساد في وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه عن وهو وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني رفض امام هذه الانتهامات وقال
ان المقارنات التي تمت هي مقارنات غير
صحيح وان المقررات تمت على سبيل المثال
تحدث عن العدس على سبيل المثال وقال ان
بعد تم المقارنه ما بين المعلبات وما بين
ما يشتريه الجيش الاوكراني وهو يشتري
بالكيلوجرام وهذه مقارنه غير سليمه وقال
ايضا ان هذا الامر الان او الدعايه هذه
يعني الهدف منها هو ان تهتز ثقه
الاوكرانيين في وزاره الدفاع وفي الجيش
الاوكراني ولكن طبعا طالب بالتحقيق ومزيد
من التحقيق وقال ان الوزاره ستكون شفافه
جدا عود الى عبد الجواد عبد الجواد
استكمال كان يقوله الزميل حذيفه هل لدى
وصفه قناعه بان المانيا لن تنجر الى ارسال
دبابات اثنان الى كيف ام لا موسكو مقتنعه
انه عاجلا ام اجلا ستنصاع برلين
والاوروبيين الى الضغوط الامريكيه وترسي
هذه الدبابات وهنا السؤال كيف سترد موسكو
طلب يعني اذا ما تم قراءه الصفحه السياسيه
او العسكريه في البلاد بما يخص قضيه تزويد
كيف بالدبابات نلاحظ بانوسكو ليس لديها
قلق كبير من وصول هذه الدبابات او تزويد
يعني الحكومه الاوكرانيه بهذه المعدات
العسكريه الثقيله يعني الموضوع لديه ااا
العديد من الخيارات الخيار الاول الذي
تتحدث عنه موسكو هي كيفيه يعني ما هي
الطريقه التي ستصل بها هذه الدبابات الى
القوات الاوكرانيه موسكو قد تقدم على خطوه
يعني غير مسبوقه وهي ضرب همم سكك القطار
التي قد تقوم بنقل هذه المعدات العسكريه
الثقيله ما يعني ان مرحله الصراع في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ستدخل المرحله جديده
باعتبار انضرب سكك الحديد سيوقف الاعمال
التجاريه والتبادل والنقل البضائع
والاغذيه للم من الاوكرانيين ستكون في
النقطه الاولى الخيار الثاني طبعا موسكو
تبحث عن عدم وصول اسلحه اكثر تقنيه لكيف
وهي الصواريخ بعيده المدى طيب همم
اعود همم
رغدا قطع الحديث معك اولا الى ماذا برلين
تتعرض لضغوط قويه من الولايات المتحده
لارسال هذه الدبابات ثم الان خبر عاجل
نريده على الشاشه وزير خارجيه ليتوانيا
يقول ان المستشار الالماني ولا في شغل
خائف من تعرض روسيا للهزيمه لانه في خوف
الماني من تعرض روسيا للخزي لهزيمه هل
يعقل
بالفعل يعني اولا الضغوط ليست فقط من
الولايات المتحده رغم انه الولايات
المتحده ربما هي الحليف الاثقل الذي
يلقي بهذه الضغوط على المانيا ولكن رغم
ذلك المانيا حتى الان لم تغيب رايها او لم
تعلن يعني موقفها لم تعلم بانها ستوافق
على ارسال هذه الدبابات ثانيا بالفعل كان
هناك كلام شبيه ايضا للرئيس اللثواني اجرى
مقابله مع احدى وسائل الاعلام الالمانيه
وكان يقول بانه المانيا امامها مسؤوليه
تاريخيه الان استذكر يعني موقعها او دورها
في الحرب العالميه الثانيه وقال بانه لو
حصل هكذا تحالف لدول مثل التحالف الان
الذي تجمعه كلندا همم لما كان يعني لما
كانت وقعت الحرب العالميه الثانيه ربما
وكان هناك من سيواجه المانيا
لذلك هناك الان ليس فقط تحميلها مسؤوليه
ولكن ايضا استذكار تاريخها واحده تحميلها
مسؤوليه تاريخيه بانه الان ربما يقع عليها
يعني حمل ثقيل جدا وعليها ان تتحرك قاله
الرئيس التواني وبالفعل يعني كرره قبل
قليل كذلك همم يعني المسؤولون من دول
البلطيق جميعهم او هناك ضغوط ايضا داخليه
طالب يعني اضافه الى كل هذه الضغوط
الخارجيه انقسام كبير داخل الحكومه
الالمانيه ربما عبرت عنه ان لنا بيربوك
يوم امس عندما قالت في مقابله لي قناه
فرنسيه بانه المانيه لن تعرقل ارسال طلب
ارسال هذه الدبابات ولكن اليوم يبدو بانه
يعني بسبب الضغوط التي تعرضت لها من
المستشار على الارجح اليوم عرفته رفضت ان
تكرر هذا الكلام وعندما سئلت عن الامر من
جديد اكتفت بان تردد بانه همم نحن بحاجه
لان نعطي كياف كامل دعمنا كي لا تفوز
روسيا بهذه الحرب لذلك الضغوط كبيره جدا
من داخل الحزبين المشاركين في الحكومه
اضافه حزب الاشتراك على المستشعر لها لكي
بالفعل يعطي موافقه لارسال هذه الدبابات
العربيه شكرا التي على هذه المشاركه شكرا
ايضا لعبد الجواد رشد كان معي من موسكو
ومن اكياس شكرا لحذيفعل
اعفى رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شريف على
السوداني محافظ المصري في المركزي مصطفى
غالب مخيف من منصبه وكلف علي محسن العلاق
باداره المصري بالوكاله كما احال السوداني
مدير المصرف العراقي للتجاره الى التقاعد
وكلف بلال الحمداني باداره المصرف وكان
معظم النواب قد قدم طلبا الى رئاسه
البرلمان الاستضافه محافظ البنك المركزي
من اجل الوقوف على اسباب ارتفاع الدولار
ووضع المعالجات
رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياعه السوداني
قال ايضا ان حكومته جاده في تطبيق
المعايير الصحيحه التي تضمن المحافظه على
المال العام فيما اكد رئيس مجلس القضاء
الاعلى في العراق فائق زيدان في تصريحات
خاصه للعربيه ان القضاء مستمر في محاربه
الفساد واسترداد الاموال المنهوبه
اجراءات القضاء الحقيقي تسير وفق القانون
في موضوع مكافحه الفساد ونعتقد من وجهه
نظر قضائيه وهذه الاجراءات التسير بشكل
جيد الاشكاليه اللي همم نواجهها انه
بعض وسائل الاعلام او المحسوبين على وسائل
الاعلام ينقلون صوره مشوهه عن الاجراءات
القضائيه ويحاولون تشويش على الانجازات
اللي حققها القضاء خاصه في ملف استرداد
الاموال المهم المخبر السري هو موضوع معقد
وقد يكون غير مفهوم هذا نصف قانوني موجود
بموجب قانون محاكمات الجزائيه انه كل مخبر
الجريمه من حقه ان يطلب حاجبها وهذا شيء
موجود
ان يلغي لكن الاجراءات قد تكون الخاطئه في
في سنوات معينه حصلت التحريك الشكاوي على
اقوال مقبل سري هذه استطيع ان ازوم انها
انتهت حاليا
قضيه اختفاء العشرات من الاطفال طالبين
اللجوء في بريطانيا
البريطانيه هناك مخاوف من ان هؤلاء
الاطفال قد تم اختطافهم من قبل عصابات
اجراميه
الصحيفه اوضحت ايضا بان عمليه خطف الاطفال
اللاجئين تمت من فندق تديره وزاره
الداخليه البريطانيه رغم التحذير المتكرر
لها كما افاده المبلغون عن تلك الحالات
لان عمليه الاختطاف كانت على الشارع
الرئيسي وعبر سيارات مختلفه
من امام الفندق الذي اختفى منه الاطفال في
برايتن ينضم اليه مراسل العربيه مصطفى زار
والذي يتابع هذا الموضوع مصطفى اهلا وسهلا
بك جديد المشهد من عندك وكيف يتفاعل هذا
الخبر
يعني هذا الخبر صدمه كبيره لاولائك الذين
يتابعون اوضاع اللاجئين بشكل عام ولكن
عندما نتحدث عن اطفال دون ال 18 بعضهم
ربما ااه في حدود الخامسه 10 هذا مقلق
للغايه ولكن السلطات المحليه ولاسيه بلديه
همم يعني برايته حيث وجد يعني همم انتقدوا
الحكومه خاصه وزاره الداخليه لم تقم بما
يجب كان هناك همم يعني انتقادات كبيره لهم
همم وخاصه فيما يتعلق بتامين حمايه وسلامه
هؤلاء الذين ياتون الى المملكه المتحده
للهروب من الحروب وايضا همم طلب اللجوء
همم المقلق ايضا وان هؤلاء الاطفال غير
مصحوبين عندما اتوا الى المملكه المتحده
ووثق القانون همم يعني المتعارف
بانه يجب ان لا تتعدى مده اقامه الاطفال
دون 18 في فنادق اكثر من اسبوعين او ثلاثه
اسابيع هناك من يقضي ربما اكثر وهذا مخالف
للغايه لانه يجب ان يكون في دور رعايه
تهتم بهم همم بلديات ال- ال- ال- يعني
المختلف المقاطعه هناك توزيع في لهؤلاء
الذين ياتون الى المملكه المتحده ولكن
بالنسبه للاطفال دون الثامنه عشر هناك
فنادق معينه ربما يعني في محاوله لايجاد
همم يعني بيوت ومنازل لهؤلاءهم وفقه
البلديات التي ينتمون اليها طيب مصطفى حتى
الساعه ما الذي قامت به حكومه ريشي سوناك
او ستقوم به وستتخذه من قرارات لمنع تكرار
مثل هكذا همم ماساه وهل هي في موقف حرج ام
لا لا تشعر باي حراره تقول يعني انه هذا
في حكومات سابقه وليس همم في عهدهم
من دون شكل هذا مقلق للغايه ومحرج لحكومه
ريشه سوناك الذي يحاول ان يتعاطى مع ازمه
اللاجئين ويريد ان يرحل هؤلاء الذين ياتون
بطرق غير شرعيه الى المملكه المتحده الى
رواندا هذه هي سياسه الحكومه الحاليه ولكن
هذا ما ما شهيدناه يعني من من اخبار حول
اختفاء همم
هؤلاء يعني الاطفال يعني همم شاهد او شخص
موظف يعمل لشركه
متعاقده مع وزاره الداخليه ل همم لحمايه
هؤلاء الاطفال يعني وصف هذا هذا يعني
اختفاء هؤلاء بالاختطاف عندما همم يعني
كتابه العنوان في صحيفه الجاردن كان هناك
كلمه اختطافته يعني بين قوسين هذا مقلق
للغايه يعني بمجرد ان تكون عنوان صحيفه
بشكل همم الجارديان يعني يثير الغضب يعني
حتى عامه الناس يقولون بان هذا لا يجب ان
يحدث في اي مكان في العالم هنا في المملكه
المتحده التي يعني تقوم بما يجب يعني يعني
ان يكون لها هؤلاء حقوق مدنيه وخاصه للطفل
الذي غير المصحوب وبالتالي يعني هناك
مشاكل ربما
ستنطوي على هكذا اخبار وخاصه في ما يتعلق
بطاعات الحكومه وتامينها لي هؤلاء القصر
الذين يلجاون الى المملكه المتحده همم من
مدينه برايتون مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو
شكرا جزيلا لك مصطفى على كل هذه المتابعه
قالت منظمه الامم المتحده للتربيه
والثقافه والعلوم اليونسكو ان المديره
العامه للمنظمه قدري اوزولاي قررت تخصيص
اليوم الدوري للتعليم هذا العام والذي
يوافق في الرابع والعشرين من يناير
للفتيات والنساء الافغانيه واضافت المنظمه
انه بمناسبه اليوم الدولي للتعليم تستضيف
اليونسكو حدثا في مقر الامم المتحده
وتخصصه حلقه النقاش الاولى لتعليم الفتيات
والنساء في افغانستان وجدت المنظمه
الامميه دعوتها لاستعاده الافغانيات حقهن
الاساسي في التعليم على الفور
مستمره وفيها ايضا
الحكومه اليابانيه تتعهد باتخاد خطوات
عاجله لمعالجه اكبر انخفاض طبيعي في عدد
السكان
ابداع جهزي العده وافردي الخبزه وادهن
اللبنه والحين وين العجينه حط اللبنه
والزعتر رشيه ايوه بالضبط اغر فيها شويه
سمان الله والخيار قطعيه ايوه غمسيه يا
سلام عليك يا فنانه كل فخر صنعت في
السعوديه لبنه المراعي الفاخره طعمها يبيض
الوجه
لم تهدا الاحداث في منطقتنا حتى يومنا هذا
واليوم وقبل ان يستريح العالم بعد جائحه
طالت البشريه جمعاء تفجرت ازمات جديده
ولكن هذه المره على مستوى العالمي
كم هائل من الاحداث والمعلومات يتدفق كل
يوم اخبار حروب وتداعيات سياسيه واقتصاديه
اصبح ما بين سطور اكثر من السطور
اسلوبا جديدا وتحليلا
يبدو اكثر تسارعا كل يوم
على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
الاسواق العربيه في هذه الاوقات على
الشاشه عربيه
[موسيقى]
تعرض الحكومه الفرنسيه
للنقابات المصممه على التصعيد بعد
الاحتجاجات الاخيره
لجات شركات تكنولوجيه عده الى التوسع خلال
فتره كورونا بسبب زياده الطلب ولكن الان
لم يعد الطلب على التكنولوجيا كما كان
منتصف عام 2020 ما غير المعادلات وادى الى
صدمه في القطاع وفرض خطط لتخفيض العمل
امازون جوجل مايكروسوفت وميتر اعلنت عن
خطط لتسريح اكثر من 50,000 موظفه
شركه مايكروسوفت وحدها اوضحت بانها تخطط
لتسريحه 10,000 موظف
وستتحمل 1.2 مليار دولار من التكاليف
لاعاده الهيكله والتسريح بينما قالت شركه
الفابيت وهي الشركه الام لجوجل قالت انها
تخطط لالغاء نحو النيه 10 الف وضيف اي ما
يعادل اكثر من 6% من عدد موظفين
هذا وتقوم الشركات على تقديم تعويضات
للعمال المسرحين تتضمنوا حزم مكافاتي
نهايه الخدمه باحجام ومدد متفاوته حسب
مكان عملهم مع تمديد فتره التامين الصحي
هذا وتتوقع المزيد من الشركات الامريكيه
انخفاضا في الوظائف لهذا العام مع تقليص
الانفاق على التوسعه
واظهرت نتائج دراسه جديده لخبراء الاقتصاد
الوطني ان دفع الاحتياطي الفيدرالي لرفع
اسعار الفائده يؤدي الى ابقاء الاقتصاد
للمره الاولى منذ جائحه كورونا
اصحاب الاعمال ما يزالون قلقين من ان
عمليه صنع القرار في الاحتياط الفيدرالي
قد تدفع الاقتصاد الامريكي بشده الى براثن
الركود خلال عام 20 23
وراى الاستطلاع ان الشركات ما تزالوا
تتوقع دفع اجور اعلى للعمال الذين تحتفظ
بهم رغم التضخم كما توقع المشاركون في
الاستطلاع ايضا انخفاض تكاليف المواد عن
ارتفاع العام السابق
مع من عمان لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا
الموضوع الدكتوره رولا عواد وهي خبيره في
الهندسه البشريه والدوليه دكتوره رولا
اهلا وسهلا بك الى نشاط الخامس من العربيه
هل من سبب برايك لحملات الصرف هذه او
التفنيش كما يقال بالعربي الدارج غير
الاسباب التجاريه والماليه والى اي مدى
سيؤثر ذلك على وضع هذه الشركات والخدمات
التي تقدمها لنبدا بجوجل مثلا
هلا كل الشركات اللي عم تنخفض عم بتخفض
عدد القوى العامله الموجوده عندها هو بسبب
انهيار الاقتصاد يعني خلينا نقول الراس مع
النظام الراس مالي عم ينهار عم بصفي في
عندنا شركات همم يعني بتكون احتكاريه رح
تكون في شركات رح يعني مش راح يكون لها اي
وجود وشركات اخرى راح تكون موجوده
واحتكرها على بعض الاسماء العالميه اللي
موجوده له اقوي الشركات اللي موجوده هلا
هذا الحكي بودينا ل همم الحساب في عنا شيء
اسمه البروليتاريا اللي هي همم يعني طبقه
من العمال راح تصفي نظام جديد موجود وينهي
نظام الراسمالي وراح تصفي عنها انظمه
جديده مختلفه تماما عن الانظمه اللي
موجوده وهذا الحكي باكده ال- ال- الشركات
الكبيره الاسماء الكبيره اللي عم بيصير
فيها من تفنيشات زي ما تفضلت غير هيك كمان
انه في عندها ما في عندها خطه واضحه ما
بطلت تقدر ان تكون بتستخدم التكنولوجيا او
ادوات اداره المستقبل بالطريقه المناسبه
الصحيحه لا تقدر انها توصل لاهدافها
بالطريقه الصح يعني فقط نوضح للمشاهدين
البروريتانيا هو مست- مصطلح من الحقبه
الشيوعيه وهي الطبقه التي لا تملك سوى قوه
عملها بالطبع سيكون سيكون لك دكتوره رولا
لبعض انه لا يعني النظام الراسمالي لن
يسمح بذلك انه ان تنشا بتروليتابيه جديده
طيب لان ننتقل الان الى العالم العربي او
الى منطقه هنا بالطبعا العالم اصبح قريه
كونيه صغيره متشابكه متصله الى اي مدى ما
يحدث في الولايات المتحده الان خصوصا مع
كبريات هذه الشركات سيؤثر حكما اا على من
طاقتنا وكيف يعني هل نتوقع انه الشركات
الصغيره الان التي تعنى في مجال الاتصال
في العالم العربي وفي منطقتنا ستقوم
بعمليات تفنيش وتسريح وصرف للعماله لديها
ايضا
نعم اكيد راح تاثر بشكل كتير سلبي على
المنطقه العربيه طالما انه احنا للاسف
خلينا نحكي دول العالم ثالث ودول ناميه فا
نعتمد بشكل كثير كبير على الدول المتقدمه
لذلك راح يصير في عنا تحديات تحديات مش بس
اقتصادي لانها اوريدي موجوده التحديات
اقتصادي عندنا تحديات اجتماعيه تحديات
نفسيه وحتى تحديات كثير كبيره التوجه
اليوم لازم يكون لا رياده الاعمال للاشياء
الاساسيه نعود للاشياء الاساسيه احنا كوطن
عربي لنقدر انه نرجع نوقف على رجلينا نقدر
نكون نقدر نواجه هذا لان انهيار الراسمالي
عم بيصير الدول العالم المتقدم واللي راح
ياثر علينا بالتالي العربيه
من عمان الدكتوره رولا عواد الخبيره في
الهندسه البشريه الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه المشاركه
تعالى رئيس الوزراء اليابانيه
هذه خطوات عاجله لمعالجه انخفاض معدل
المواليد في اليابان وقال لك شيدا في خطاب
خلال افتتاح الدوره البرلمانيه لهذه السنه
انه سيقدم خططا لمضاعفه ميزانيه السياسات
المتعلقه بالطفوله بحلول
وقد شهدت اليابان انخفاضا قياسيا في عدد
المواليد في عام 20 21 ما ادى الى حدوث
اكبر انخفاض طبيعي على الاطلاق في عدد
السكان النشره الخامسه المفصله للاخبار
التحيات مزيد من المتابعه على مواقع
التواصل اضافه الى موقع العربيه التحيات
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]